turning now to the challenges facing u.s
schools where kova testing is now an
essential part of just staying open and
keeping your kids in the classroom
nearly 4 500 schools had to cancel
in-person learning for at least one day
last week due to this omicron surge meg
oliver has more on this story from new
jersey
as a mother i just can't afford to like
close the school again because it's
going to be tough for me and for them
single mom raquel tejada's sixth grade
son rayleigh helped take care of his
younger brother while the two were
remote learning but starting today
patterson public schools returned to the
classroom thanks to a rigorous testing
program ahead of their return the boys
came to one of their district's 12
testing sites the district is offering
cova testing for its 25 thousand
students and 4 000 employees eileen
schaefer is the superintendent being
vaccinated being boosted
and having a test is the answer as cases
rose the district contracted an outside
company to run the voluntary testing the
cost is covered by insurance and the
testing company is able to get
reimbursed by the federal government for
those who aren't insured many districts
have launched or participating in
testing programs but at times there have
been issues with test shortages slow
turnaround for results and poor
participation
in portland oregon the public school
district says around 13 000 of its 48
000 students are partaking in their
weekly testing program in new york city
a recent analysis found just a third of
students opted in to their testing
program
megan fitzpatrick is an expert on
infectious disease modeling if we could
have every student take a rapid test
before they went to school in the
morning that would be the gold standard
fitzpatrick says districts should try to
aim for 80 percent participation in
testing and a 24-hour turnaround for
results in addition to billions in
federal funding the white house recently
announced each month it would send an
additional 10 million kova tests to
schools but for some the help may be
coming too late we had a very high
positivity rate from the start of the
pandemic so we had to take it into our
own hands and do what we needed to do
for our community
to try to limit remote learning many
districts are now adopting test to stay
policies where despite coveted exposure
students can stay in school as long as
they're asymptomatic and testing
negative as for those tests from the
white house districts who applied to get
them are expected to start receiving
them by the end of the month tony all
right meg thank you very much